[Music]
foreign
if you're here then you already know who
she is
Lydia tar is many things
as a conductor tar began her career with
the Cleveland Orchestra Chicago Symphony
Orchestra the Boston Symphony Orchestra
until she had last arrived here at our
own New York Philharmonic in 2013 Berlin
elected tar as its principal conductor
and she's remained there ever since
Lydia tar is also written music the
stage and Screen she is one of only 15
egots meaning those who have won all
four major entertainment Awards thank
you for joining us Maestro thank you
how's the writing going
[Music]
hearing something
oh measure the man's intelligence
against his sensitive sensitive and
noise
do you ever find yourself overwhelmed by
emotion yes yes it does happen
[Music]
we have a problem
I received another weird email
there's no reason to get caught up in
any intrigue
I'm worried I'm starting to disappear
into herself
you want to dance the mask you must
service the composer
[Music]
supplement yourself your ego and yes
your identity
you must in fact stand in front of the
Republican Garden
alliterate yourself
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]